I'm curious to how did you schedule over
200 screenings of the film I mean what
was the process like and you're reaching
out to various countries or at North
Korea I think I heard you say in a fire
interview in India and things and how is
it received what do you do this via
email I mean basically what what that
journey has been is a mixture of
festivals and planning and the initial
thing is that the film opened it they
did for festival and Amsterdam which I
guess is the biggest documentary
festival one of the most prominent ones
internationally and it because it was up
for a competition it was more it was
more visible so lots of people saw it
and it did well in that if we keep it
was one of the top ten audience
favorites and and that then meant that
other people wanted to show it in their
festivals and we thought well that would
be great that you know what continues
being seen in festivals but then and our
very clever producers anyen Ricky and
Ben campus who planned this amazing
outreach campaign and somebody else who
had done fantastic community work called
Rebecca Dave and our supporters from the
MND Association they kind of all got
together with us too and discussed how
we could really capitalize on people's
interest and decided to have a global
screening day where for one day which
was the 21st 21st unicorn side of the
global awareness week yeah they
basically invited people to screen the
film which they did through a web link
or through blu-rays gaylord through
through DVDs getting sent or players
getting sent and it was screened and a
mixture of cinemas village halls
community centers churches people's
living rooms literally all over the
world on that one day and but the screen
is just continued I mean this last week
it's been in Latvia
it's been New York it's been a it's was
in Lebanon recently you know it's as you
said North Korea China I mean so many
countries right i believe i saw an
interview after the Edinburgh Film
Festival where one of the participants
just said that it really makes you
question I don't know if I could be as
strong you know watching the two of you
on there and I'm curious what do people
say if you've attended the screenings
for any qas do they ask your questions
or they actually tell you about their
own experiences with something similar
they do you ask but they do ask his
questions I mean I think the obvious one
that I am that I'm asked a lot is how
intrusive did it feel and I think I've
explained out already i think that that
is the assumption is that it would be
intrusive and it and it really wasn't
because our privacy had already
completely gone and but i think mainly
people want to thank us for making a
look at their own lives and and they
have this appreciation of the little
things which for me is just fantastic
and i love that they're coming out if
the film saying it's uplifting and
life-affirming and you know it's not
depressing we weren't depressing people
you know and it just it's it's I always
say to people all we did was tell our
story and it didn't seem like a
difficult thing to do I am it still
doesn't seem like a difficult thing to
do and it's just quite a small thing
really
but I think that's what most people
assume that it was a huge thing for us
to do and and it was very easy
you